welcome to no man's sky version 1.2
the Pathfinder update veteran explorers
can now experience the ultimate
challenge with permanent death mode and
attempt to reach the center of the
universe in a single generation normal
in survival mode difficulties have been
adjusted and damaged starships now crash
land on planets and survival mode
new trophies are available for those who
can master perma death and survival
difficulties
pS for pro support has been enabled
allowing players to explore the universe
in 4k resolution improved lighting
effects include HDR supports crepuscular
race and ambient occlusion EXO craft can
now be constructed and summoned at any
time allowing for easier planetary
navigation
[Music]
the roller EXO craft is capable of
traversing even the most difficult to
raise
and can be customized with advanced
upgrades to further increase their
effectiveness and speed
[Applause]
[Music]
suppressed can function as remote signal
boosters capable of locating and
navigating to distant points of interest
[Music]
explorers constructions are now shared
online and can be visited by other
travelers
communication terminals allow isolated
Wayfarers to post subspace messages for
others to discover
[Music]
traders at space stations and bassists
offer access to dozens of new
construction modules and technology
blueprints the travelers of high
standing
Multi tolson starships now feature
specialization system allowing players
to tailor their equipment to suit rolls
like Explorer fighter and trader
[Music]
new base building parts allow greater
customization when constructing their
homestead
[Applause]
travelers can research and build three
unique xo5 vehicles each with its own
strengths
[Music]
document your journey with photo mode
change the time of day and weather and
add photographic filters
my from the comfort of the
an efficient vehicle mounted laser
finder update is the next step in the no
man 5 journey
more will follow